ママが本当に赤ちゃんの待機を抱っこして、空港まで迎えに来てくださったのね。
それでアミちゃんはアブエロがちょうどいらっしゃると待ってるんだって言って、
ママが出た時と同じ格好をして、同じままも座って、カワイトルになっちゃって。
こんな、なんか、アスティックの石があるじゃない。
それに乗せられて、それをまたベッドの上に乗せて。
ママが空港に戻ってくる間、ジュースのままはいたって言ったら、カワイトルになっちゃって。
何それ?
大人しかったんですよってアブエロが喜んでらっしゃって。
そりゃそうよね、そんなとこでアミちゃんは泣いたりしないよね。
え、そう?
これ、コンフィメーションだと思う。
そうかな。
これ、フェンシスキンチャンポルセンターだよ。
まあ、そういう話を聞いたもんね。
うん。
あれ?
タパフィメーションはもちろんいいんだけど、今、何もしてないから、あんまり友達とかいなくて。
前、おにぎり作るのがあったのね。
うん。
あ、ほら見て。
それで、それやってたんだけど。
あ、ほんとだ。
これ、ムーメンに送る。
うん。
これ、なんだろう。
これ、誰のコンフィメーション?
うん。
これ、誰?
これ、誰だろう。
これ、誰のコンフィメーション?
うん。
これ、誰?
誰だろうね。
本当?
どっかに一人だけ、この人は知ってるっていうのがいるのかな?
ファーダーラッスルしか覚えてない。
あ、いたいた。
でも、リキちゃんもみんな一緒に、あの、可愛い。
あ、いいね。
ファーダーラッスル。
これ、ファーダーラッスルかな。
うん。
え、これ、いつ?
今、どこいらっしゃったか知らない。
あの、この間、みんなで、みんなで行ったので、その後、全然、何も、何も言ってないから。
あ、こうすけさんか。
うん。
そうです。
かわいい。
かわいい、これ。
うん。
何か食べて。
この人たち誰?
これ、何か食べて。
これ、これ、これ。